il commence à faire chaud ici 15 minutes
avant le retour du merveilleux helvis
coulé vous allez l'adorer
comment ça va Justin ton expression me
dit que tu as encore des problèmes avec
tes hémorroïdes la seule chose que je
suis dans le cul si c'est toi tête de
gland le bateau est en train de couler
il s'intéresse pas à des médias sociaux
tu vois je suis animateur de radio pas
danseur sur Tik Tok
parler à Elvis sur la ligne
comment allez-vous
faut respirer fort comment ça va garer
car lui je sais pas si c'est une sorte
de blague c'est mon arme appuyez contre
la tente de ta fille
explique-moi ce qui se passe et tu as
faim de l'émission C'est une créer aux
gens de Bose je veux détruire ta vie
comme tu as détruit
la police va rentrer de chercher si tu
ne te rends pas mais je ne porterai pas
plainte je veux juste que tu laisses ma
femme
non ne me retirez pas descendre on m'a
dit que j'étais brisé psychologiquement
laisse ma femme et ma vie partir ça peut
encore bien se terminer
mais je veux pas que ça se termine bien
qu'est-ce qui se passe la police dit que
il y a personne dans la maison mais je
suis réellement avec ta famille Elvis
va-t-on d'ici on se battue sans crier il
va tout faire sauter les fenêtres la
porte le sous-sol le garage il a
installé des explosifs partout il est
dans le bâtiment si on veut pas mourir
il faut qu'on se batte le gars qui se
balade avec une famille une petite fille
est-ce qu'il parle dans vos écouteurs en
ce moment
il nous observe depuis le début si vous
me trouvez je mets pas sauter le
bâtiment mais je tirer quand même un bus
laisse partir mes filles ok je suis
beaucoup trop vieux pour jouer à
cache-cache d'accord je pourrais jamais
oublier ses yeux je veux dire il était
complètement coco car il est policiers
sont sur le point d'entrée je t'en
supplie pitié en toi
je crois pas que je vais arriver à faire
ça salut fils de [ __ ]
ça pourrait faire un bon film tu en
penses quoi je crois que ça mérite une
réécriture